now i brought up that of course uh max
gonna max the east street bank going to
be playing
uh in houston and uh which will be very
ironic
because uh tonight on our show involves
a guest involves houston
uh we're gonna have for the first time
ever hilton
the chainsaw guy now let me explain a
little background here in case you're
confused
we recently had a contest on our show
involving two of our sponsors
in the city of houston you see folks in
houston
unlike the rest of the country our show
comes on at 2
10 in the morning that's two and a half
hours after jay says
stay tuned for conan
they show this two and a half hours
right
correct me if i'm wrong jay says that
and that's like when jay leno tells you
something that's supposed to be a pact
with the american people
exactly he's giving his word exactly
this mean
creepy cruel station in houston doesn't
show us
they're mad at us for some reason and
they delay us and they show outtakes
from mod the old mod series that's what
they show
they show b arthur bumping in yeah see
that makes sense
right no they show all kinds of random
stuff
they show like richard simmons sobbing
some show where he just cries or
something
they show all kinds of uh crap for two
and a half hours
and then finally finally uh in
our show comes on yeah yeah in what's
really 2 10 in the morning is crazy
and being on at that late hour means you
get some interesting sponsors
all right some really interesting
sponsors so we decided to pit
two of these sponsors against each other
in a contest where our viewers get to
pick
their favorite pitch man well a couple
of weeks ago we announced the winner
hilton of hilton furniture let's take a
work it's
uh let's take a look yeah thank you
dyslexia please let's take a look at
some of his work
hilton hair hilton furniture and
mattress announcing the big price cut
[Applause]
we're cutting prices on wood bedrooms
and dining rooms for a limited time
oh we're cutting prices on mattress is
true hilton furniture matches
big for sale just inside the beltway
look for the facts on because we're
cutting prices and that's a fact jack oh
we're at cutting chrysler and that's a
fact jack
commander now
now folks uh hilton's prize was an
all-expense-paid trip to new york to
appear
live on our show but we also thought it
would be great if we treated hilton
to an advertising makeover that's right
that's right we thought an advertising
makeover with the biggest advertising
company in the united states
fcb this is a real slick advertising
company
so we took them there to give him a
makeover here's a tape
of our little visit
hey i'm here at fcb this is the number
one advertising agency in the united
states
number five global these guys did the
gatorade
ad where gatorade comes through michael
jordan's skin
[Applause]
really disgusting they did the
amazon.com
ads you've seen everywhere
they did the third most popular ad in
the super bowl
tropicana pure premium with calcium so
if anybody
can help hilton the chainsaw guy i think
it sees people
right here i've got a meeting scheduled
for right about now
let's go so we're sitting here with the
creative team
uh for fcb and everyone here is in black
which is i guess a new york
advertising thing uh i won't play that
game you two are defiantly in gray which
i like
and you're wearing sort of an off green
so you're clearly they're phasing you
out
what would you normally charge someone
who came in here and said i want a top
spot
uh i want an advertising campaign what
kind of money are we talking about we
don't charge by the spot
but right you know millions of dollars
several millions of dollars
what's the cheapest ad that you've ever
done and how could i achieve that level
of achievements
last year we did the yogi berra museum
for nothing the yogi berra museum has an
ad
the way advertising is portrayed in
bewitched is that fairly accurate
is there usually a client you have to
have dinner with and at the last minute
your wife who's a witch
performs magic darren gets upset and
says i'm sorry this will never happen
again
the client says are you kidding it's the
best evening i ever have and i love it
as a design concept and then mr tate
apologizes and says
uh i had that idea all along is that
fairly accurate
what i'm going to show you now are some
of hilton's spots his best spots that
run
in houston where our show airs at a
shocking 2 40 in the morning
uh let's take a look hilton half kills
the furniture mattress announcing the
big price cut
where are current prices on wood
what message did you get when you watch
that commercial very little do you know
what
what exit he's on in the fuqua exit i
did see that
the chainsaw was not actually on i
noticed the the
sound effect of the chainsaw was headed
afterwards are you kidding
you guys are you know that chainsaw
wasn't really on they put a special
effect in there that's the kind of
cynicism
and i don't mean this in a harsh way but
that's the kind of cynicism that i think
is destroying the country
and that's why i think john mccain
should be our next president
all right members of the cynical
advertising community of new york i give
you
hilton hi there connect
how are you good morning so help me
ready to get to work i'm ready to go
all right here we go how won't you have
a seat right over here
perfect i don't know if you're aware
this this is the number one advertising
agency in the united states
number five global soon to be number
eight uh
i'll tell you about that later it was in
the paper this morning what's the
information that you have to get out
pretty much it's tell us the information
you have to get out of course the name
of the store
right the exit the exit and the location
location and that's a [ __ ] jack hey
that's a fact
where'd you come up with that's a fact
jack well when we moved into the
building
of course we didn't have any kappa 2 to
to do anything
and the fact sign was at the uh on top
of the building
and i had to incorporate that into what
we were doing
so you had to use a pre-existing sign
and that's where you got that's the fact
that
right yeah it's like edison in his lab
accidentally
mixed two materia two materials and and
got the light bulb
uh was an accident get the camera off
man
would you be willing to let to be shot
on camera
and what i mean shot i mean with a gun
not in a vital area but if we promoted
that
conan o'brien's going to shoot hilton in
the shoulder and when and
my dad's a doctor i'd pick a place that
i wouldn't hit bone i'd try not to hit
bone
be honest with me is this something how
bad do you want this
i'd probably take the shot you take the
shot yeah
before you uh pass out you give you know
exit uh
basically where the store is located
that's an advantage
what is it it's an event say it again
it's an event i'll say one more time but
like with a french accent
you shouldn't have been all right we
don't have to have full chance though
i mean that's something that we can work
around also you don't take away
superman's cape
[Music]
we're in the uh main presentation room
at fcb and uh this is pretty exciting
isn't it oh it's very exciting
the creative team here has been working
this week
on an idea and they've got something
that they want to show us
you guys happy with what you came up
with yeah very
this is the best advertising company
in the united states it's number one
right and globally i think they're
like number 26. okay we talked about the
um the chainsaw you know and how it was
um emblematic for cutting prices which
is the main reason people will come to
your store
so that's what we've tried to do here is
to take your
chainsaw technique and as jen said
elevate it to
a whole new level all right well what's
the best thing maybe we should take a
look at the ad right now
and uh liza do you want to hit the
button
[Music]
michael tiger
[Music]
mia
[Applause]
hilton as the great ones know
if you do your work well all the world
will profit from it
hilton's furniture great furniture
greatly reduced prices and that's a fact
jack yeah yeah i'm thinking yes what do
you thinking oh i'm thinking high five
me brother
let's do a double high five yeah i love
that
yeah yeah you're up there with
who's the basketball player michael
jordan he's
it's basketball right my thought is
you don't hear the chainsaw in the sad
mm-hmm
and yet that's the loudest i've ever
heard that chainsaw does that make sense
yeah
would you explain it to me because i
have no idea
uh the check is in the mail i was told
today
and if there's any problem with the
check which or shouldn't be
you uh you know where to get us we're
over at abc
uh i do a show called who wants to be a
[Music]
[Applause]
millionaire
[Applause]
all right everybody you don't want to go
anywhere tonight
until we come back hilton the chainsaw
guy's gonna be here
you